First, how do you get to high school in America?
Well, when I was in high school or junior high, there's no Internet, so I can't...
...like look up things in America.
So, I bought this magazine called "Ryugaku Journal"...
Uh-huh!
...and they listed all the schools, high schools in America like East Coast, West Coast,...
Wow!
...and I looked for the schools, high schools with no Japanese students,...
Cool! Good approach.
...'cause I didn't know any other way. I mean, how can I compare, you know.
Sure. Well, that's brave of you though.
A lot of exchange students choose high schools or schools...
...with a lot of Japanese people, so they'll have friends.
Yeah. And I refused to take up ESL.
Really?
Yeah, because if you're to begin with surrounded by like no known speakers, how can you speak?
Yeah, like my wife. Let's say my friend went to America and...
...took two months of English study at an ESL or any English as a second language school,...
...and she came back to Japan speaking English like a Mexican...
...she's like, "Hey! It's very hot today".
You know?
Yeah.
But have you had a lot of Mexican teachers?
No. But actually, my ESL, I didn't pay...
...those classes taught by a French teacher who, you know, has a thick, French accent.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, it's the same as, you know, a lot of American kids learn Japanese from an American teacher.
And so, they come and say something like, "Watashi wa",...
..."watashi wa onaka ga suita".
Yeah. But, you know, what can you do?